اعلن مركز الدفاع الاقليميه تابع لقوات
دوناتك المواليه لروسيا عن مقتل مدني
واصابه تسعه اخرين في قصف اوكرانيا على
احياء سكنيه غربيه المدينه واضاف المركز
ان القوات الاوكرانيه استهدفت بقذائف
مدفعيه وصاروخيه مكثفه سته مناطق سكنيه
خاضعه للسيطره الروسيه في
تضرر 22 منزلا وثماني منشات للبنيه
التحتيه
في غضون ذلك ذكر الجيش الاوكراني ان روسيا
ضاعفت عدد سفونها في البحر الاسود ونقلت
وسائل الاعلام المحليه عن القياده
الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه ان عدد سفن الروسيه
في البحر الاسود ارتفع حاليا الى سبعه
عشره سفينه بما في ذلك خمس حاملات
الصواريخ وغواصه
لمتابعه الموقف
الميداني تحديدا على جبهه ضخموت
مراسله الجزيره عامر لافي من دونسك مراسل
الجزيره امين درغامي
عامر يعني ما زالت القوات الروسيه تحاول
اختراق
الخطوط الاماميه للقوات الاوكرانيه على
محاور بخمه مع العلم ان هناك حديث عن تقدم
في اكثر من محور اين وصلت القوات الروسيه
حتى اللحظه
نعم نعم حسن وفقا لمصادرنا في القوات
الاوكرانيه التقدم الحاصل الان هو في
المحور الشمالي وان كان بطيئا جدا كما
يقولون نعم اقتربوا من الطريق الالتفاف
المستخدم لايصال الدعم الى داخل مدينه
مخموت لكنه لم يتم قطع هذا الطريق نعم
اخبرونا بان الوضع في شرق المدينه معقد
ومعقد جدا وبان هناك تكثيف كبير للهجمات
الروسيه في محاوله لدفع القوات الاوكرانيه
الى الضفه الغربيه من نهر محمود الذي يقسم
المدينه واكدوا لنا بان الوضع في الجنوب
وان كان هناك تكثيف للهجمات عكس الايام
الماضيه لانه يبقى الاقل خطرا بخصوص الوضع
في محاور القتال في محمود ونقص طبعا
الثلاث محاور لكن ربما اللافت اليوم حسن
تصريحات وزاره الدفاع نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه التي تحدثت عن ارسال قوات
جديده الى مخمود في الوقت الذي يتوقع
الجميع وينتظر فيه ربما اعلان انسحاب من
هذه المدينه تتحدث هنا مليار عن ان بعد
زياره قام بها قائد القوات البريه
الى مخمود قرر ارسال مزيد من القوات
الاوكرانيه الى هذه المدينه وقالت بان
التمسك بهذه المدينه ليس قرارا سياسيا
وانما استراتيجي يتخذه العسكريون وربما
حسن تفسير يمكن تفسير هذا القرار
الاوكراني بالحديث الذي جاء على لسان رئيس
المخابرات الاوكرانيه قبل عده ايام عندما
قال بان الدفاع عن مخموت هو ليس دفاعا فقط
على هذه المدينه وانما دفاعا عن المنطقه
ككل الدفاع عن مخمود اذا سيطرت القوات
الروسيه عليها فهذا يعني ان القوات
الروسيه لن تتوقف عندها عند حدود هذه
المدينه وانما ستتقدم الى هنا الى
كراماتورسكوفكا وكوستانتينيف كهذه المدن
الكبرى في شمال دونس وهذا سيكون خطر على
هذه المدن الامر الاخر الذي قاله
رئيس المخابرات هو ان
المواقع التي يتمركز فيها الجيش الاوكراني
تمكنه من ايقاع الكثير من الخسائر
والتكبير القوات المهاجمه من فاجنر والجيش
الروسي الكثير من الخسائر يقول بان تمكنا
من ايقاع كل هذه الخسائر سيجعل هذه القوات
مستقبلا غير قادره على تنفيذه هجمات كبيره
كالتي تجري الان على مخموته وبالتالي واضح
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تريد ان تستفيد من
هذه المواقع الى اقصى حد لكن نعود واقول
واذكر بان الرئيس الاوكراني كان قد قال
باننا لن ندافع عن مخموت حتى اخر رجل
والقناعه هنا حسن انهي بان القناعه هنا
بانه اذا ما ايقن الجيش الاوكراني بان هذه
المدينه ستحاصر فسيكون هناك انسحاب
اوكراني منها ولم يتكرر السيناريو ماريوبل
الذي يعني المشهور والمعروف في بدايه هذه
الحرب
اذا هناك تصميم اوكراني على عدم الاستسلام
في باخموت والدفع بالمزيد من التعزيزات
العسكريه هناك ما العقبات التي تواجه
الموالين لروسيا في حسم هذه المعركه
كان هناك عائق واضح ومعروف تحدث عنه كثيرا
مؤسس شركه فاجنر ريفجيني قبل ايام يتمثل
في ذلك الجدل الذي خلقه موضوع ايصال
الذخائر الى قوات هوجنر وذلك الخلاف الذي
طفى على السطح بين مجموعه فاجنر ووزاره
الدفاع الروسيه لكن الامر تغير بتوصل الى
اتفاق وببدا وصول على ما يبدو الذخائر الى
جبهه ماخبوط وهذا ما اتضح الان من خلال
هذا التقدم حينما سئل
يفغيني قبل ايام عن تكتيك قوات اي شركته
العسكريه في معركه فوجنر وقبلها معارك
اخرى في بابارسنايا
ايضا وبعض البلدات في اقليم دومباس شبه
تكتيك هذه المجموعه العسكريه بلعبه
الشطرنج لا يمكن في الحقيقه ورغم القراءات
العسكريه الكثيره هنا من قبل الموالين
لروسيا للتحركات فاجن التكهن وتحديد ما هي
الخطوات التي تقدم عليها قوات فاجنر مع كل
معركه فهي تلتف حول الطرق تقوم باختراق
مدن
وبمحاصره بعض المناطق الاخرى تقوم
بالسيطره على مصانع كبرى ومن ثم محاصره
قوات في مناطق ضيقه لنقل وهنا اعني القوات
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي هذا التكتيك يجعل من
معركه بخموت كغيرها من المعارك السابقه
التي خاضتها
غير واضحه المعالم ولا يمكن لعلكم تسمعون
الان القصف الذي يدور هنا غير بعيد
وتحديدا في جبهات الذي لا يمكن التكاهن
بتحركات الرغم ان الحديث الان يجري عن نقل
القوات الاوكرانيه
لقواتها الى مدينه
المجاوره واحداث خط دفاع متاخر في هذه
البلده ما يرجح
بعد اكمال معركه بخموت الى تشوسوفيار
ومنها الى كان قسطنطينه المجاوره عكس
التوقعات التي تقول او تذهب باتجاه
امكانيه التوجه فاجنر نحو كراماتورسك
التوجه الى كرامه
يبدو من خلال المعطيات من خلال قدرات هذه
المجموعه العسكريه غير يعني منطقي لنقل
لعده اعتبارات اولها ان قوات فاجنر ليست
بالمجموعه العسكريه الكبيره اذا مقرناها
بقوات لوغانستا
او حتى بعض الفرق والوحدات العسكريه
التابعه للجيش الروسي النظامي وبالتالي
يعني اي حديث عن خريطه المواجهات تحديدا
في ذلك المحور خلال المرحله المقبله يبدو
من السابق لاوانه بها ما يجري هنا قرب
مدينه دانياسك حيث نحن اليوم هناك قصف اي
متبادل عنيف بين الموالين لروسيا والجيش
الاوكراني في محور افديفكو واخر الاخبار
القادمه من هناك من هذه المدينه على ان
القوات المواليه لروسيا تحاول اختراق
دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني ليس من الشمال كما
حدث قبل اسبوع لكن الان الحديث عن خطر
الجبهه الرئيسي المرسوم منذ عام 2014 وهذا
ما يرجح ان ان هذه المنطقه ستكون على
اعتاب معركه كبرى لربما خلال الايام
القليله المقبله
شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر كذلك عامر لا في من
كرامه